so who takes more accountability men or
women men men men men men men
why you're shaking your head I think
women are right we easily say sorry men
don't say sorry as much as women so
definitely but men say sorry and then
continue to fix it whereas women can't
say sorry and then continue to make the
same mistake I think women rarely say
something I don't think
across the board I've I've never most
men one of their biggest gripes is that
women they will always move the goal
posts like if they're wrong then they
will kind of CounterPoint on how they
like how you caused it like even if they
cheat well you weren't emotionally
available so it's your fault no matter
what happens there's an excuse I rarely
hear a woman say I'm sorry honey I did
wrong I'm going to work on it you'll
never see me do this again please
forgive me well I think that's exactly
that's exactly accountability
[Laughter]
not in all situations but I do think
women held their hands up more than men
men Gaslight that's the thing there's
accountability and gaslighting so
so um I think that there's a difference
within our society I think that women
have the privilege in our modern day
society today to not be held accountable
I did a story not too long ago about a
year or so ago just popped into my head
where a young lady went down the NBA
All-Star weekend with not enough money
to get back home she then goes on
GoFundMe in order to get money in order
to go back home men cannot do that right
men do not have that type of reach and
or access to get free money sent to them
if they make a boo-boo I don't
so
Society in general just last Quick Point
Society in general has cushions put in
place for women more often than men
that's why most homeless people in
America are men it's like 90 to 10
percent 90 yeah I think when you say
that if you if you go on the modern day
tick tocks and whatever right you'll
find videos of women saying oh how to
apologize to your man just scoot up to
him naked with your ass out right and
that shows a lot of non-accountability
that shows when you say that okay women
are more accountable it's like no that's
how they apologize they think okay if we
have sex then everything's fine and so
yeah I think women don't hold themselves
accountable a lot I think women have a
hard time having that introspection I
think if you do they try to attack
people more so than actually accept that
I think in the time though well we live
in a time where women don't really need
to be accountable in a way that men
always run around after him which I
think needs to stop and that's why that
they never have to really hold their
hands up and say look I'm sorry what
I've done wrong I'll try to fix this
because before it becomes an actual
issue the man's already there trying to
fix what they've done kind of
listening because I feel like in America
this is not the stance right I feel like
the men that I have come across in the
dating spectrum they are very passive
they are not quick to apologize they are
very gaslighting they don't accept
accountability into your point about a
man not being able to go to Vegas get
stuck and not make his way back you've
men these days because they're in the
streets doing whatever have accumulated
a bunch of women that care for them you
can paint her a sob story and she's
going to send you a hundred dollars
because she's caring and wants to
support you right so I think it's a
balance of each depending on the
circumstances in the person but I
definitely think women can be
accountable and from my circle and my
experiences are more accountable in this
generation of men who don't accept
accountability are not they Apologize by
actions right they just show up they
won't accept accountability for what
they did specifically a blanket apology
is not an apology if you are not owning
right that's the definition of lack of
accountability if you oh I'm just sorry
but what are we sorry for what are we
making improvements on right so I have a
question for you what was the last thing
that you apologized for what was the
last thing you took accountability for
um bad communication bad communication
yeah okay what you had something to say
think maybe sometimes when I lose my
anger sometimes I'll blame it on other
things then the last thing I took
accountability for is when I got no do
you know what I overreacted with that
and I shouldn't have reacted in that way
so I apologize for that
can we clarify that accountability is
not the same as an apology right versus
accountability means that there is a
consequence after the action so either
that means okay you did that and because
of that this is the consequence and I
believe that is what men have to deal
with I think a lot of times women think
just by saying I'm sorry I'm accountable
that is not the same thing the amount of
times that I'm in dating relationships
with different women and listen they
just want to just complain about the
problem
I want to fix the problem correct I
don't want to continue to listen to you
just talk about what happened with you
and Marianne in the office right if you
come to me with an issue let's talk
about Solutions all right okay you can't
just waste my time at like that at the
end of the day let's talk about
Solutions but I find as though a lot of
women don't communicate in Solutions so
we talk about accountability the
consequences for that is to solution if
men in general are not accountable they
will not be successful if women in
general are not accountable they can
still be the wife to a CEO and but they
can go on only fans using using that
analogy that same woman will complain to
you about you know um what happened at
work you will say as a man okay cool
what we gonna do about it what are we
doing about how are we going to fix it
how are we going to fix this she would
say oh I just wanted to vent and then
the next week or the next month she'll
be complaining to about the same thing
so it's like okay but
how would you hold yourself accountable
do you want to face this woman or
whoever you have a problem with do you
want to get it out into the air do you
want to help the situation no they just
want to vent so yeah women talk a lot
but they don't
do a lot when somebody commits a crime
do we blame the criminal or do we blame
society
I think
good men can become bad where usually
when you see men that have turnt bad I
think they always started out as good
men but being around certain people in
society can change them and twist them
for them so you guys think it's 50 50. I
wouldn't say 50 50. yes
on the street and I steal something is
it my fault or Society no it's true it's
your fault it's nothing to do with
Society like if we want to blame the
system then that's the that's the that's
the Crux of no accountability like like
if you want to just blame love my
childhood my upbringing I didn't have
this I didn't have that the same person
grew up in the same circumstance as you
and they made other choices so we have
to like that's not accountability if
it's if it's always somebody else you
know who who caused it because you were
raised a certain way I can show you the
example of somebody raised in a worse
circumstances who made better choices
than you so is it really Society if if
we can if I can point to one person who
made a better choice sorry if I make if
I could poison one person who made a
better choice then
like like you haven't your excuse is
gone but there's a moral and there's a
moral story in that so for instance if
you look at people like Robin Hood right
Robin Hood was born into a poor Society
right and what he chose to do was to rub
from the rich and give to the poor right
so was he was he wrong so I have a
question so if a guy cheats can he blame
society no no
absolutely not no he has no no
discipline with his tool
um
but I think it also depends on your on
your end goal so like I said with Robin
Hood with the Robin Hood analogy he
robbed from the rich gave to the poor to
try and change society so so women were
like they they this woman
and these poor women out here aren't
getting enough D he's giving charity
I'm talking about it because that's
essentially what your example is no I'm
just talking about morally depends
that's why I said it's depends I never
said this 50 50 I said it could also be
the society could also be the individual
I'm just saying I would say it would
depend on what you want from say so
people like if you're trying to change
society for instance look at Andrew Tate
he's trying to change society right but
he's deemed as wrong that's why he's
been jailed just people don't like to
right because people don't like Taylor
trees
If we're honest but he's done things
right I will say there are moves he's
made that people are on on his side will
say listen you you self-snitched like
you you should have kept it quiet
there's moves that he needs to do what
I'm talking about that we're talking
about whether he's is that society's
fault of you self snitch is he wrong
and for what he's trying to do if you
sell snitch you have to learn how to
move we're in the world we're in and I'm
not saying he's right or wrong what I'm
saying is but that's what we're talking
about but I'm saying is but he has to
also does Andrew Tate have to take
accountability if he self-centered but
if you if you you can sing about
something in a song or talk about
something on social media without it
technically being self-snitching they
have to bring evidence that you did
those exactly they have no evidence
against him so I agree with you they
have no evidence so they need to let
that go their feelings are hurt so
that's why I said Society because
Society could deem somebody wrong
because they're the ones in the room so
if I have power my original question was
about the CH about the stealer so if I
go down and steal is it my fault or
Society it's your fault your fault but
let's just think if you're if you're
raised in poverty you have no money
you're in a circumstance where you have
no food and you're raising us and you're
living let's say you're a kid and you
have no money you have no food you're
dependent on parents who are on drugs
and and your your baby sister needs to
eat your mother's on crack like there
are nuances in this where you have to
blame a portion of society that this
child out has failed because we've let
them slip through the system
but how would that child eat how do they
eat tell me the solutions if their
parents are on crack their baby sister
their little brothers and sisters are
hungry they can't get a job they're 13.
I personally know of people like this
kids in homeless shelters this is their
situation Maggie understood that wrong
is still wrong there may be reasons why
this kid is stealing but we still have
to be able to say wrong is wrong and as
a parent I mean you hear it even in
parenting advice you know they tell you
oh the child is not bad they just made
bad decisions where I grew up in an era
where if you were a fool they called you
a fool yeah and I think we need to bring
some of that back because it breeds this
thing well it's not my fault sometimes
it just has to sit on you and you just
have to realize I did that and it was
wrong so is that a moral question then
like when you say wrong is wrong because
who decides what is wrong and what is
right but then the question is well if
you are let's say you're a teenager or
young your mother's on crack there's a
reason store in the U.S wore a mother
left her two children her 14 year old
ran away her 12 year old and she has a
three-year-old all three different baby
daddies she left him alone in Texas in
Houston for two months through
Thanksgiving she told them if you tell
anybody that I'm leaving that they're
going to take your little three-year-old
brother away and you'll never see him
again and threatened her so she was
scared to tell anybody what was going on
her mother was missing for two months or
she was running the streets in another
state she was left in the carrot she
never enrolled these children into
school
the oldest one so she used to have to
lie to her father who was working in
another state because of course she got
custody of all the kids okay so then she
because she was threatened because the
mother said I'll never love you or see
you you'll never see your siblings again
this child had to lie to her father and
say can you please get groceries mom is
working he would call the mother say
yeah I'm working can you please send
groceries or food I'm struggling but she
couldn't tell the truth because she was
scared if that instance if she didn't
have food who didn't have the father who
would who would send the groceries or
food to the house and she had to go
steal are we going to say little 12 year
old you are now accountable because your
mother's for the streets and abandoned
you in your in your little sibling and
now you need consequences I think
there's you can have empathy for a
situation but the whole idea is wrong is
wrong exactly I mean your mom
and you could say this is why I did that
wrong thing and like this is my reason
for it but wrong is still wrong
it doesn't become right just because
something happened exactly it doesn't
matter well that's tough for me that one
that's a tough I think it's odd so
suppose it's the instance if I got up
and slapped you in your face right now
am I wrong yes sir yeah if you slap me
back are you wrong yes no no but
remember you made decision to slap me no
because once in self-defense
if he just slaps you once and then he
just stands there and there's no defense
needed he just slapped you it's still
self-defense though right
shooting and go sits back down
right here stand up and do it again but
but what if he doesn't what if like he's
held back are you are you should you be
able how would he be happy how do we get
here
I'm like we've gone in the past I think
you've gone in the past yeah I think you
why is it that when a man cheat He
Cheats he's a cheater but when a woman
cheats she's not satisfied in the
relationship as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible